what are we actually confident enough to
say we know about the Stargate movie
that we're hoping Amazon is about to
announce welcome to psycheck your Sci-Fi
TV and Movie Channel
[Music]
so we've been talking about Stargate a
lot as you know and I I'm always really
careful to try and tell you what room
what is maybe going on and what we
actually know
and I'm gonna do two videos now to talk
about the Stargate movie that I believe
Amazon is planning and what I am
confident enough to tell you we know
about what is going on and then I'll do
a second video to tell you the stuff
that we're not so sure about but that we
believe is happening so first of all
there has been a lot of internal
fighting between MGM and Amazon there
really is no cohesion between the top
Executives at Amazon and MGM they're
really nice two camps a lot of
Executives believe that actually
Stargate should return with a serious
LED potentially by Brad Wright and that
that is the only way to really be
confident that a Stargate revival can
work there is another Camp though that
really want to start off with a movie
now this Camp is led by Jennifer sulky
the problem is Jennifer selke is in
charge of MGM and Amazon so really it's
her decision that matters she has been
championing a movie since very early on
2022 and basically through the summer
now we know that no decision was
actually made about whether to do a
series or a movie until January this
year that's when the decision was made
now we also know that there was a bunch
of pitch meetings
um and last summer August through
September Amazon put out a request a few
months earlier and actually asked
companies to come forwards with their
ideas on how to revive or reboot the
Stargate franchise several companies did
we know the Bad Robot did we know that a
couple of other companies did we
actually know that Bad Robot not only
put a movie Pitch forward but we
actually found out what that movie Pitch
was and it basically involved ra coming
back which is just stupid but we also
know that they didn't win now it does
look very strongly like penguin in the
Parker was actually the winners now we
don't know that for a fact but I'm
included in this video because what we
do know for a fact is for two or three
months following these pitch meetings
Mark Fergus the head of penguin in a
park are the guys that did the expanse
was in negotiations with Amazon about
doing the Stargate franchise he was
requested to do a Bible of the Stargate
project something that other companies
could use if they weren't successful to
actually then build the franchise around
basically a set of rules a set of do's
and don'ts if you will for whoever then
does do the project there was then two
or three months of negotiation but those
negotiations ended roughly just before
Christmas 2022
again we don't know for certain why
these negotiations failed but we do know
that one really big irritation that Mark
Focus had was that there was no decision
about whether it would be a series or a
movie or both and that this was
basically meaning he felt he couldn't
move forward at that time now we don't
know what has happened to those
negotiations since but we do know as I
say the Jennifer selki did make the
decision in January very early February
that a movie was going to be the
direction they were very least initially
going to be taken
now at that time Amazon and MGM movies
didn't have a head of film now Jennifer
sarki is the head of Amazon Studios and
MGM Studios but she isn't actually in
charge of what films are going on they
were in the process of hiring somebody
after Pam Abdi left very shortly after
the actual acquisition of Amazon was
finalized
now Claudia Valentini who is now head of
film for MGM and Amazon was hired in
March and we know that a couple of weeks
after she began work just after she got
all the pot plants in place and put a
few pictures on the wall that she was
instructed by Jennifer sulky via memo to
actually begin the production process
for the RoboCop movie and Stargate now
that has actually been confirmed by a
couple of other insiders
um but I know that it happened because
basically I have one source that saw the
instruction so we know that that
happened now the development stage of
any movie can be a very long process
Amazon's plans have obviously been
hampered by the strikes but they have
been moving forwards we know for a fact
again because of different sources that
I speak to the Amazon and MGM did start
in formal conversation with a short list
of directors we know that those
directors were really the creme de La
Creme of up-and-coming sci-fi directors
we did have a few names we've spoken
about them in previous videos several
informal conversations were had with
four different directors through March
and into April now apparently informally
a director has been chosen but we don't
know for certain who it is now even
though I have actually been told who
this
preferred director is I don't really
want to talk more about that at the
moment because basically the sources
don't allowed to
um but basically what he's saying is
that the director will not sign up while
the strikes are going on he considers
that to be disrespectful for the general
strike and he is choosing not to confirm
until the strikes have concluded I can
tell you that this director if I can't
name as I said Has Done Sci-Fi movies in
the past has actually a rich background
in sci-fi and has a background with MGM
and has links to several of the leading
people on the previous Stargate
franchise so they do have a background
in this area they are sci-fi people
but there are downsides for this person
that previous movies have perhaps had a
bit of an agenda that does concern me
slightly but basically as long as Amazon
very early on tell him you know you will
do a Stargate movie not a movie about
this agenda then I don't think it'll has
to necessarily be a problem now the only
other thing the final thing that we know
for certain is that this was going to be
announced to San Diego Comic-Con now
there have been some rumors knocked
around that there was a promo created
etc etc but those rumors are not true
apparently in March it was decided that
actually they were not going to announce
it San Diego Comic-Con as they had
previously planned they were only going
to announce the intention to bring
Stargate back they were not going to
announce anything else it was just going
to be apparently Richard Dean Anderson
Amanda Tapping a couple of others on
stage and they were basically going to
say Amazon is bringing it back and
that's all they were going to actually
announce at the time
obviously once the strike started in
March they realized Amazon that they
were pretty confident the actors were
going to go on strike as well and that
basically following advice from a couple
of different PR firms it was decided
that it wouldn't be in Amazon's best
interest to announce anything major
during the strikes so as I say in March
those plans were scrapped so that is
basically why I am confident enough to
say we know about what is going on with
the star game movie anything else
I'm only you know 50 50 sort of thing on
but the information in this video I am
absolutely dead on certain is actually
happened now it doesn't mean that these
things won't change the strikes
unfortunately have thrown everything up
in the air a little bit but for right
now we can be sure that Amazon are
working towards a cinematic movie that a
director is at very least
in Theory been signed on that this was
supposed to be allowed to San Diego
Comic-Con but will be announced at some
point and finally something I haven't
mentioned up till now there is a script
now that script has been in development
for at least six months but again until
a director signs on and a director
decides on the direction of the movie
nothing is set in stone so guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
is everything that I've talked about
stuff that excites you do you think
we're moving in the right direction if
it wasn't for these bloody strikes it
would have been actually announced by
now and I would actually love to know
what do you think about it being a movie
first now I know a lot of you are not
very happy about it we've talked about
it a lot on the channel and a lot on the
lives but now it's sort of sunk in a
little bit are you changing your minds
at all actually does a two-hour advert
for what will then follow that you've
had time to you know mull it over a
little bit if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to sidetrack.com
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts and for a small
contribution each month you even get a
free gift
also you can go to
sidetrack.co.uk that is our dedicated
website we do articles based on all of
the videos that we do we try to add a
little bit more information for you to
consider
go and check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time foreign
[Music]